it was what a sports darkest episodes a
much bigger scandal with Russian
athletes than we knew
following the Sochi Winter Olympics of
2014 Russia was proved to have carried
out a vast state-sponsored doping
operation conspiracy to conceal positive
tests widespread doping by Russian
athletes at the Sochi Olympics I don't
think anyone was expecting the gravity
in terms of the findings in terms of the
cheating the scandal didn't just expose
an epidemic of foul play he called into
question the credibility of a system
that's supposed to guard against doping
and protect honest athletes it still
smells of bias towards the interests of
sports governing bodies to the detriment
of the athletes doping is definitely bad
for business and it's used as an
illegitimate excuse to russia under the
log or ignore that completely so is
there a lack of will to catch the cheats
doping isn't just a Russian thing it's a
global problem in 2011 an anonymous
survey asked more than 1,200 athletes
whether they'd used
performance-enhancing drugs the results
which was kept quiet for six years was
astonishing
44% admitted to doping but typically
only one to two percent of samples test
positive our career our livelihood are
our name is based on making sure that we
stay clean and we compete fairly Callum
Skinner is a retired track cyclist a
gold and silver medalist at the 2016 Rio
Olympics now he campaigns to keep doping
out of sports what we have to do is to
send a clear message that if you do dope
it comes with negative consequences just
like the Olympic motto athletes want to
be faster higher stronger
performance-enhancing drugs
promise just that but all drugs come
with health risks and crucially they tip
the balance in competition the sports
governing bodies especially the
International Olympic Committee or the
IOC say they want to stop the cheats but
antoine de val a leading sports lawyer
believes they are part of the problem
they have an incentive of being seen as
doing a lot but they don't have an
incentive to catch a lot of cheats
because that would damage the image of
their sport back in 1999 the IOC
declared war on doping it created the
world anti-doping agency or a wada
well that would be very useful for the
fight in the future against doping wada
was set up to be the anti-doping
watchdog and to write the rulebook that
would dictate best practice
globally but wadis independence is
questionable Rob Keeler has unparalleled
insight as the former deputy director at
wada
he knows the pressures facing the agency
as water became stronger there was
resistance from the Olympic movement
where there was a desire to have more
control when you lose control you lose
the ability to dictate the outcomes 50%
of wadis funding comes from 190
governments and the other half comes
from the IOC and wadis average annual
budget of 27 million dollars is less
than 2% of the IOC s revenue in an
average year we need to understand that
wada as an institution is weak is
basically a naked legislature it
produces rules that it has absolutely no
power and capacity to enforce wada has
around 120 employees only seven of them
are tasked with conducting
investigations into doping schemes
worldwide so it's extremely dependent on
goodwill with no power to enforce water
relies on the National anti-doping
agencies in sports federations to do
drug testing but different countries
have different means ability and yes
political will to catch dopers and
that's why the Russian could run a very
neat front organization that was
apparently in compliance with those
rules while systematically bypassing
them
the 2014 Sochi Winter Olympics were a
huge success for the Russian team two
years later in just weeks before the
opening ceremony at Rio 2016 something
happened that no one had anticipated
grigory were chenkov the head of
Russia's anti-doping laboratory turned
whistleblower his admissions captured in
the oscar-winning Netflix documentary
Icarus thrust Russia's actions into the
public consciousness like never before
I was hoping to facilitate one of the
most elaborate doping boys in sports
history wada had been investigating
allegations of Russian doping since 2014
but it wasn't until July 2016 that it
published a report conducted by
independent lawyer Richard McLaren the
Moscow laboratory operated within a
state directed failsafe system Russia
tampered with urine samples of athletes
in a thriller like cover-up operation
Russia was found to have mouse holes to
slip samples through in the middle of
the night and switch urine samples they
even mixed in salt and coffee to
contaminate doped samples more than 1000
Russian athletes were accused of doping
Russia was categorical in its denial you
go to the nebula nyan you know you can
cook we his team of flesh conducting
wada was determined that Russia should
pay the full price the water executive
committee made strong recommendations
that the Russian Olympic Committee be
banned from the Rio Olympic Games I
recall being so proud of the
organization I work for but the IOC
rejected what is recommendations the
basic and the difficult question we had
to answer was can you hold any athlete
responsible for the wrongdoing of the
government of his or her country
the IOC allowed individual athletes to
appeal against the decision at the Court
of Arbitration for sport or Cass
the result over two-thirds of the
russian team were allowed to participate
two years later the IOC cleared 169
Russian athletes to take part in the
Winter Olympics but were those outcomes
entirely due to concern about the rights
of individual athletes the answer may
lie in a complex web of politics and
power in sports
Russia is a powerhouse in sport and they
provide a lot of money into sport they
host a lot of events in the sport and
there's this Russian politics in sports
I'm very often omission Alexander Zhukov
Russia's Deputy Prime Minister doubled
up as president of the Russian Olympic
Committee Pavel calleb qov was deputy
minister of sports and part of wada and
then there's Vitaly Mutko he was sports
minister during the Sochi scandal but he
wasn't sacked for this embarrassing
episode in fact he was promoted to
Deputy Prime Minister but placing
influential people in positions of power
isn't just a Russian affair the IOC has
two bodies that are predominantly
dedicated to fighting doping wada and
the Court of Arbitration for sport casts
like wada Cass was also established by
the IOC these two bodies are meant to be
independent but an intricate network of
rules and people has raised questions
well I think it is a very small
community in terms of sport there's a
lot of conflicts of interest where
people are feeling different roles
three senior IOC members Thomas Bach
Craig Reedy and John Coates have held
key positions at the Cass and Atwater
often at the same time and the list
doesn't end there
should the president of wada also be an
IOC member where there's a divergence of
loyalties you don't see the president of
the u.s. sitting in at the same time in
the sprinklin this is not the way to win
this inner circle mentality means that
the IOC maintains a tight grip on the
bodies it had set up as independent IOC
is an elitist Club of the highest kind
all those executives of sports raise at
least a suspicion then there might be
something for you despite its 5.7
billion dollar revenue per Olympic cycle
the IOC is registered as a nonprofit
organization and benefits from
Switzerland's lenient Association laws
which means it has a lot of leeway and
how it runs itself and raises the
question is anyone governing the
governing bodies we have private
associations that exist sizing
government governance and they are proud
of it but they claim it without the
strings that traditional public
authorities in demócrata countries at
least are subjected to which are
transparency accountability etc so can
anyone hold the IOC to account I put
some of the blame on on sponsors and
broadcasters 73% of the IOC s revenue
comes through TV rights they're the ones
supporting and promoting the Olympic
Games surely there should be an a
responsibility from the broadcasters
that are sponsoring from the sponsors
demand change
the IOC insists there's no inherent
conflict of interest in its relationship
with wada and has stated its desire to
make testing more independent from
sports organizations and governments it
claims that a 20 million dollar
investment into anti-doping research and
the protection of clean athletes is now
bearing fruit but some athletes believe
this should just be the start as soon as
athletes start to lose confidence in the
system they start to think Pocono win if
it's not a level playing field people
will always find ways of trying to cheat
but what we need to do is get better at
catching them and I think one of the key
ways that we can do that is if sports
governance officials wake up to the
responsibility to athletes the
responsibility to protect fair and clean
sport their responsibility to protect
the welfare of the athletes and the
responsibility for athletes to have
faith in the anti-doping system if you
want more information on doping in
sports click the link opposite where you
can find further economists coverage and
also all the research data and studies
that we used to make the film if you
enjoyed what you saw and I hope you did
then click that subscribe button and
also click that little bell next to it
and you'll get a notification next time
we publish a film thanks for watching
you